foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar monkeypox
epidemiology clinical features and
diagnostic testing
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by CG Technologies
to learn more visit cgtech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Dr Matt vinegar director of clinical
virology and professor of laboratory
medicine and pathology at the Mayo
Clinic
Dr biniker you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for the introduction thanks
everybody for joining me today for this
update on monkey pox
um as you probably have seen in the news
monkey pox was recently renamed by the
World Health Organization to impox
that is the new name for the disease
they're they're still is a chance that
the virus name will be updated as well
but I'm going to be referring to Monkey
pox as impacts per the updates from the
World Health Organization over the
course of this presentation so we'll be
talking about the epidemiology of
impacts the clinical features and how we
should go about testing for this disease
in The Clinical Laboratory also before I
begin want to thank lab roots for
putting on this uh and coordinating this
webinar presentation and for sieging for
sponsoring the event
also
um just to disclose some conflicts of
interest I am an Advisory Board member
for Dia sworn molecular and Mammoth
biosciences and I've received honoraria
for several educational presentations
from the companies listed below
so we'll go ahead and dive into the
presentation and you know it's been a
rough couple years for all of us 2020
was difficult with stay-at-home orders
and the covid-19 pandemic 2021 really
felt like it was going to be the year
where we were going to pull out of the
pandemic vaccines were available and
I've heard from many that it felt like
2021 was going to be the time when we
were jumping out of the burning building
into the arms of safety unfortunately
2022 rolls around and we continue to
have surges of covid-19 in certain parts
of the country a influenza outbreak now
that we haven't seen the likes of in in
years and of course who would have
thought a monkey pox outbreak and so
instead of falling into the arms of
safety in some ways it's felt like we
have bounced into another burning
building but I'm hopeful that 2023 is
going to hold a lot of promise and
hopefully will be much quieter for all
of us
so the objectives for today's
presentation is I'm going to walk you
through some key epidemiologic features
of mpox and we'll try to highlight why
the current outbreak of this viral
infection is unique it's not the first
outbreak but it definitely is unique as
we contrast it with other outbreaks that
have occurred over the past few decades
we'll try to draw out and describe the
clinical features of impox disease and
I'll highlight why this is a challenge
for our providers and Physicians because
of the variability and clinical
presentation that's being seen in this
particular outbreak
and then finally I'll point out the
different laboratory methods that we
have in our diagnostic toolbox that can
be used to assist in the diagnosis of
the Spiral infection and talk about how
we can use those laboratory methods
along with the clinical presentation to
help establish a diagnosis of impox
infection
but before we do that I wanted to start
with a patient case and this is a case
that we actually encountered at Mayo
Clinic earlier in 2022 and I think it's
a really good example of the type of
clinical presentation
of applications of various laboratory
methods and definitely underscores some
do's and don'ts when we encounter a
suspect monkey box case
so as is usually the situation
um it's a Friday afternoon at 3 P.M when
the laboratory staff here at Mayo Clinic
give me a call
and they indicate that they have an odd
viral culture result that they'd like me
to come down and take a look at and yes
Mayo Clinic at the time was still
performing viral cultures
we've since discontinued viral culture
testing of respiratory samples because
of the covid-19 pandemic and dermal and
genital samples because of the ongoing
monkey pox outbreak but at this point
the lab saw this odd viral culture
result and wanted me to come down and
take a look
so I went down to the lab and they
showed me this image that's projected on
your screen so in our laboratory we
would inoculate two different types of
eukaryotic cells with samples from
patients one is cells derived from
rhesus macaques kidneys so these are
primary kidney cells and the other cell
lines are a human a human
medical research Council five or mrc5
cells and so what we're seeing here are
the rhesus monkey kidney cells three
days after being inoculated with a fluid
from an anal lesion swab and what you
can see hopefully on this image are
there areas where it looks like the
cells are rounding up other air areas
where you can see more spindle-shaped
cells but really focus in on those
refractile rounded up cells that to our
laboratory staff were concerning for
some type of a a viral infection what we
would do in this type of a situation is
after those initial cells showed that
cytopathic effect the the lab staff
would then passage those cells into
fresh uninfected rhesus monkey kidney
cells
and this is what we saw in those passage
cells so about 24 hours after the
passage was completed we saw
um more Progressive cytopathic effects
so more areas of involvement and you can
see now at around the seven o'clock
position a nice cluster of rounded
refractile cells that are kind of
grouped together another example about
the 12 o'clock position
and this was definitely of concern for
our laboratory staff but you might be
asking why was this a concern why
wouldn't this just be uh considered a
normal viral culture finding
so this was a red flag for a few reasons
first and foremost the cytopathic effect
that I showed you actually resembled
what we would see with another common
viral infection called adenovirus
so when we see adenovirus grow in
eukaryotic cells the cytopathic effect
that occurs is described often as
grape-like clusters and so if you
remember back to the prior two slides
you could see how there were areas that
could be described as clusters of grapes
however the laboratory thought of this
and they did a quick direct
immunofluorescence test on the viral
culture for adenovirus and that was
negative so that really ruled out
adenoviruses the cause of what we were
seeing
second we saw more rapid growth in those
rhesus monkey kidney cells compared to
the other cell line that we inoculated
which is those medical research Council
five or mrc5 cells and so when we see
better growth more cytopathic effect and
one cell line versus another it can give
us an idea of what viruses may be
causing the infection versus what
viruses may not be present
and then finally the specimen type that
was sent to us it was an anal lesion
swab and so when our laboratory receives
certain sample types they're able to put
together a list of potential suspect
viruses and from a dermal genital lesion
swab we usually would grow herpes
simplex virus that's by far and away the
most common virus that would grow from
that type of a specimen but if it would
have been HSV the cytopathic effect
would have been as pronounced or
probably more pronounced in the human
cell line than in the rhesus monkey
kidney cell line so for those reasons
the laboratory flagged this is a bit
abnormal and wanted me to come down take
a look and provide some some feedback
so after seeing the microscopy results
walking back to the office I knew that I
needed to get some additional
information on this particular case to
really be able to determine what the
possible viral infections were in this
instance
I was able to get that information
pretty quickly and the specimen had been
sent to us from the state of Arizona
the patient uh is a 29 year old male HIV
positive and the clinical records
indicated that this individual had a new
sexual partner two weeks prior to the
sample being collected
about a week after his last sexual
encounter he developed a puritic
postular lesion on his inner thigh and
he also developed a headache and body
aches
so when the patient's symptoms first
began to appear he was evaluated at a
County Health Department sexually
transmitted disease clinic
and at the STD clinic the patient was
tested for chlamydia gonorrhea and
syphilis all
typical STDs that might be causing these
types of symptoms and the testing for
those infections came back as negative I
mentioned that this patient was known to
be positive for HIV but at the time of
presenting to the county health
department STD clinic his HIV viral load
was undetectable
his CD4 account was marginally low but
not extremely low at 480 cells per cubic
millimeter
and
without a defined diagnosis this
individual was treated empirically
with Ceftriaxone azithromycin and
penicillin he was also started on valet
cyclovir for possible
HSV infection
foreign
but the individual's symptoms didn't
really improve over the following week
and because of that he decided to
present to his local emergency
department
so when he was examined in the emergency
department he was found to be a febrile
he had normal vital signs denied a sore
throat didn't have any neck stiffness no
nausea vomiting
notably he did have a palpable right
inguinal lymph node so just file that
away as interesting information that
there was an enlarged lymph node in his
groin
he also had this papular lesion on his
inner thigh he also had developed
recently a raised anal lesion that was
described as papular and I'll show you
that on the next slide
so here are the images that were taken
in the emergency department so on the
left hand side you can see the remnants
of this inner thigh lesion definitely
not something that would stand out as
significant but because he had had this
over the course of the last week week
and a half it was photographed
more pronounced was the anal lesion
which had been present for only a few
days and you can see that on the right
hand side of this slide
so the physician in the emergency
department felt like this was likely a
diagnosis of molluscum contagiosum
because of the umbilicated appearance of
that anal lesion so if you're not
familiar with molluscum
here's an image of what molluscum
contagiosum can appear as so you can see
why the emergency department physician
might have thought that this was
molluscan contagiosum because you see
that indented
umbilicated appearance of the lesion
as we saw on this patient's anal lation
now what happened was that the physician
requested a swab of that anal lesion be
collected and that it'd be sent in for
viral culture and unfortunately no other
microbiology studies were ordered no
bacterial cultures no molecular studies
for other viral pathogens and the
patient was discharged from the
emergency department and instructed to
complete his seven-day course of valet
cyclovir
so you might imagine that as I'm
gathering this information I'm getting
more and more concerned because this is
around
July of 2022 as we're beginning to hear
reports of increasing numbers of impox
infections in the United States this is
the right
patient the right clinical presentation
negative
studies for other infectious diseases
like chlamydia gonorrhea syphilis
and
I'm really thinking this could be
impacts
now interestingly our laboratory had
just finished validating a real-time PCR
test to detect impox virus just the day
before
and so
after reviewing the patient's Medical
Records I talked to the lab and said why
don't we go ahead and take this sample
and have it tested by our mpox real-time
PCR just to be sure
that it's not impacts well
four hours later I got a knock on my
door and of course the result was
positive for impox virus
so
this was a case of impox and
it's probably the first time in my
career that the first actual clinical
sample that's tested by a new assay
turns out to be positive for the virus
that we're looking for but that's just
how the last few years have got has gone
so we're going to talk more specifically
about this virus and its epidemiology
and the Very clinical presentation that
we can see
so this is an enveloped virus
and it possesses a DNA genome and you
can see a really great image provided by
my friend and colleague Ryan Relic on
the right hand side of what this virus
looks like
it's a member of What's called the ortho
pox of orthopox virus genus and the
orthopox virus genus consists of other
viruses such as variola or the causative
agent of smallpox as well as camelpox
cowpox vaccinia virus
impox virus was first identified in the
late 1950s during an outbreak of a
pox-like illness among monkeys that were
being used for research studies and
that's really how this virus got it the
original name of monkey pox virus
it wasn't until 1970 that the first
recorded human case of impox virus
occurred in the Democratic Republic of
the Congo and so we've known about impox
virus in the human population
for over 50 years
but as we'll point out there's something
very different and unique about the
current ongoing outbreak of this virus
across the globe
so historically this virus has been
considered a viral zoneosis
which is endemic to the Democratic
Republic of the Congo in Africa
uh we don't know exactly what the
natural reservoir for the virus is but
there is
um
some data suggesting that rodents and
non-human primates are the likely
natural reservoir for where this virus
resides before it crosses over into the
human population
there are two phylogenetically distinct
clades of impox virus
the first which was previously referred
to as the Congo Basin or Central African
clade has now been renamed or
reclassified as clade 1.
and the second which was previously
referred to as the West African clade is
now referred to as clade 2. these two
different clades carry with them
different disease severity so the
Central African clade 1 has a mortality
rate approaching 10 percent whereas the
clade 2 virus has a mortality rate of
around one percent or less and
fortunately it's the clade II virus
that's the causative agent of the
ongoing outbreak
worldwide and that is why fortunately
we're seeing to date relatively low
numbers of deaths due to epox virus
infection
so prior to this year outbreaks of this
virus outside of endemic countries in
Africa have been extremely rare
and the outbreaks that have occurred
have been associated with contact with
animals from Africa or travel to Africa
now there has been a large outbreak in
the United States prior to this current
outbreak and that occurred back in 2003
but the scale was dramatically different
in 2003 there turned out to be 47
confirmed cases
and the investigation that occurred
during that 2003 outbreak showed that
those who became infected all had
contact with pet prairie dogs
and it turned out that initially there
was concern that the prairie dogs were
reservoirs for impox virus
but it was determined that those prairie
dogs were being housed in the same
facility in cages near other small
mammals that had been imported from the
continent of Africa and specifically
Ghana
and the animals were the giant African
pouch rat which you can see on the right
hand side of your slide
and what was determined to be the case
was that the giant African pouch rat had
been infected with impox virus and then
infected the prairie dogs which were
then purchased and taken home as pets
and they then caused crossover infection
into the human population
so I was able to get a few images from
actual skin biopsies from those two from
the 2003 outbreak from my colleague
Bobby Pritt
and it's interesting to look at the
pathology of what's occurring in an
impox virus infection
so you'll see that at the top of these
images are areas of clearing of the
cells or edema so this is basically
where fluid is filling these areas and
causing these opening areas where there
should be dermal cells and this is
actually
where the vesicles would occur over the
next of the course of the next few days
if this were allowed to progress
so this is again fluid-filled vesicles
resulting from impox Virus Infection the
other thing that I'd point out is if you
look at areas where there's darker
staining that's usually in
histopathology areas that we want to
focus in on and if we zoom in on those
darker staining areas you can see that
there are some multi-nucleated cells and
also I'll point out what's referred to
as an intro intracytoplasmic inclusion
which is described as a granary body it
was actually a description of made by an
Italian physician Dr guarneri who showed
that these intracytoplasmic inclusions
can be common in patients infected with
impox virus
so the 2022 outbreak
the first case was detected in early May
of this year and it was an individual
who resided in the United Kingdom and
had recently returned from travel to the
country of Nigeria
as of a week ago there are now over 80
000 confirmed cases globally the United
States is leading the way at close to 30
000 confirmed cases Brazil at over 9 800
cases in Spain at approaching 7 400
cases
we're seeing impacts virus in 110
countries the majority of those being in
areas where impacts has been considered
non-endemic so on areas where we haven't
seen this particular virus causing
outbreaks in the past
55 total deaths to date 12 in Brazil 14
in the United States so again in
comparison to what we've experienced
with the covid-19 pandemic the number of
total deaths is relatively low but still
55 total deaths worldwide from the
current outbreak is something for us to
keep a very close eye on
so I've been asked many times over the
last few months why are we seeing an
impox virus outbreak in 2022
to this scale
this is really the first time that we've
seen an outbreak of impox virus
with wide transmission outside of
Central and western Africa and many
nations around the world
in the past all of the prior outbreaks
have been associated with contact with
an animal from Africa or travel to the
continent of Africa and that is not
something that is associated with the
current outbreak the current outbreak
actually is mainly associated with close
intimate contact
resulting from person to person spread
of the virus
and because of the scale of infections
and the number of countries involved the
World Health Organization declared this
a public health emergency on July 23rd
of this year
so
the CDC and the World Health
Organization are actively studying the
virus that's in circulation and to date
there hasn't been results based on
sequencing that would show that there's
a significant genetic difference in the
currently circulating strain that would
account for
an increased transmission rate or a
reason why the outbreak is occurring now
in other words there doesn't seem to be
anything genetic about the virus the
current virus that would explain why
we're seeing an outbreak in 2022.
there are some likely explanations the
first and foremost is the decreasing
population level immunity to smallpox
so many of your parents Grandparents
great-grandparents were vaccinated
against smallpox virus and you'll
remember that smallpox is a member of
the ortho pox virus genus and there's uh
protect cross protection of smallpox
with impacts and so smallpox has been
eradicated now and so there's a
decreasing number of people across the
globe who are receiving smallpox
vaccinations so we have declining levels
of immunity to that virus and therefore
declining levels of immunity cross
protective immunity to impacts
we're also seeing today more Global
Travel than ever before so a virus in
one corner of the the world can reach
any area
across the globe in less than 24 hours
and the mode of transmission that we're
seeing with this particular outbreak
along with personal behaviors I think
these are all contributing to
this large worldwide outbreak of mpox
virus
so in terms of different modes of
transmission of the virus we already
pointed out that in past outbreaks it
usually resulted from direct contact
with an infected animal and in the
continent of Africa this is typically
how an impox virus outbreak initiates is
someone from a community comes in
contact with an infected animal and that
can result in and cross over into the
human population and typically
controlled or small levels of
transmission within the community what
we're seeing now though in this
particular outbreak is large levels of
person-to-person spread primarily
through direct contact with an infected
lesion and most not all but most cases
in the current outbreak have resulted
from sexual transmission
there are a few other routes of
transmission that are possible one that
we've learned a lot about over the past
few months is the possibility that the
virus can be spread through contaminated
fomites and fomites are inanimate
objects such as bedding towels unwashed
clothing
that if an uninfected person comes in
contact with
can actually cause a transmission event
and there's been a number of really nice
studies now looking at detection of
impox virus on Fall mites and these
Studies have shown that the virus can
persist for weeks on porous material
like towels and clothing
the virus can be recovered and cell
culture
PCR Studies have shown that the DNA from
the virus can be detected for weeks
and so this is one possible route and
has been shown to be confirmed as a
route of transmission and a small number
of cases during the current ongoing
outbreak
finally there's been some talk about
whether impox virus can be spread
through the respiratory route I'll just
say it's a possibility not likely but a
possibility and if it were to occur it
would most likely require
prolonged
face-to-face exposure in the in the
range of several hours of uh time for an
infected individual to be able to
transmit epox virus to an uninfected
person through respiratory droplets I'll
just say that if respiratory
transmission was a predominant mode of
transmission we wouldn't be talking
about 80 000 confirmed cases we'd be
talking about 8 or 80 million confirmed
cases of impox virus so I don't think
that this is a predominant means of
transmission
so in terms of clinical features
on average the the mean incubation
period is around seven days it can occur
um as soon as three days after exposure
or as long as up to three weeks but on
average it's about seven days
the clinical presentation that we're
seeing during the current outbreak is uh
a
wide distribution of clinical
manifestations from extremely mild to
severe
the initial symptoms can involve fever
chills headache body aches usually a
rash develops one to three days after an
individual develops a fever
and remember when we were talking about
the patient case that the the patient
developed an enlarged lymph node in his
groin and lymphadenopathy is a key
distinguishing feature from smallpox so
in patients who had smallpox we wouldn't
see enlarged lymph nodes where it seems
to be more common in patients with impox
virus
now a challenge associated with the
current outbreak is that very clinical
presentation
six months ago if you had been asked
what impacts looks like or how a patient
would present you would probably
describe something like the image on the
right hand side of the slide a patient
with hundreds of lesions
that were characteristic and and not
typical of other infectious or
non-infectious causes of skin lesions
unfortunately this is not the
presentation that most patients are
presenting to emergency departments and
Clinics with instead these are the types
of lesions that patients are presenting
with you can see a wide distribution in
the appearance of these lesions from
what looks like a pimple on the fourth
image from the left
and then on the thumb on the far right
hand side that may be
um similar to a lesion that might be
found on a young child that has hand
foot and mouth disease caused by
Coxsackievirus
so this is what is a challenge for
Physicians who are seeing these patients
is it doesn't always stand out as
something that could be impox virus it
could be some other infectious cause of
the lesion in some cases may even look
like a pimple or something that's
non-infectious
so I'm sure that there are situations
where patients present with mpox virus
lesions that are determined or thought
to be due to something else and testing
is not performed as was the case in the
patient case that I described
so with regards to diagna Diagnostics
it's really a combination of exposure
history the clinical presentation and
laboratory confirmation as I highlighted
in our patient case this virus will grow
readily in eukaryotic cell lines
with a cytopathic effect appearing on
average in about two to three days after
inoculation now just because the virus
will grow well in eukaryotic cell lines
doesn't mean that we want to order viral
culture in fact viral culture should not
be ordered in cases of suspect and pox
virus infection and that's because
cultivation of this virus in culture
represents a safety hazard to our
laboratory staff instead we have a good
molecular tests available now that can
detect impact specific or non-variola
orthopox virus DNA in specimens like
dermal and genital lesions
so with regards to collection of samples
for diagnosis of impox virus infection
the current recommendations from the
Centers for Disease Control are to
submit two swabs either dry or in viral
transport media from two to three
suspect lesions so why would we want to
collect swabs from several different
lesions that's because patients may
present with lesions that appear
differently some of the lesions may not
be due to impox virus whereas others
might and so getting a collection from
at least two to three different lesions
increases our probability of detecting
an individual who's infected with mpox
virus
there was a really great study that was
published a few months ago comparing
different specimen types in patients
with impacts virus and the data really
showed clearly that swabs of the dermal
or anagenital lesions is by far and away
the best specimen type for detection of
impox virus the virus can be detected
from other sites and and Sample types
includes including the nose and the
throat
uh the blood urine and semen but at much
lower uh rates than the lesions of the
skin and genital tract
so we've talked briefly about safety
precautions for laboratory staff and
when
our laboratory staff are working with
samples from suspect impox patients
if they're working with non-lesian
specimens such as urine and blood those
sample types can be worked with using
standard precautions and a biosafety
level 2 environment and those staff who
are again working with urine blood-based
samples don't need to be vaccinated
against impox virus
lesion samples are a bit different and
it's recommended recommended that when
possible staff be vaccinated
against smallpox and pox
and that can provide an additional layer
of protection for those laboratory staff
for non-immunized staff the CDC
recommends to use bsl2 precautions with
a special practices or bsl3 like
practices and I'll go into a bit more
detail on this slide
so in those situations what we want to
do is have our laboratory staff working
with samples inside of a Class 2
biosafety cabinet they should be wearing
a solid front gown with cuff sleeves
they should be double gloved and wearing
eye protection or a face shield if
they're going to be performing any
aerosol generating procedures such as
vortexing a tube that's open in 95
respirator is recommended but I'll say
that that probably isn't being done in
most Laboratories
just recommending not to perform aerosol
aerosol generating procedures
and having those samples being worked
with inside of a Class 2 biosafety
cabinet with the other measures listed
here on this slide
in terms of vaccination and treatment
there are two vaccines available for
prevention of impox disease the genius
vaccine is approved for prevention of
both impacts and smallpox and is the the
vaccine that's being used most
predominantly across the United States
there is a second vaccine listed here
that's approved for prevention of
smallpox but has been made available for
immunization against impacts under an
expanded access IND
the genius vaccine is given via
intradermal injection similar to a TB
skin test
and the vaccine could be administered
pre-exposure or if someone has been
exposed to someone who may have impacts
the vaccine can be given as a
post-exposure prophylaxis to help
prevent disease onset
there's also an antiviral called tpox
which was approved for treatment of
smallpox but is being used in some cases
of severe impacts disease and I'm sure
we'll begin to see more data come out on
the efficacy of teapots treatment for
treatment of mpox
so I want to wrap up just with some
future considerations and unanswered
questions regarding the current outbreak
I'm often asked will this virus be
contained and will it completely go away
in developing nations in the United
States and I really think at this point
it's unlikely to be completely contained
and go away we are at over 30 000
confirmed cases of mpox virus infection
in the United States and my guess is
there are many undiagnosed cases out
there that aren't recognized is it going
to become an endemic disease in other
words will we be detecting impacts virus
in the population
uh in in the future and I think that
that answer is likely this virus is
probably at this point well entrenched
in the population
and outside of a global vaccine campaign
against the virus I don't think that the
virus will completely be a eradicated in
the 110 plus countries that have now
been confirmed to have this virus
and will we be testing for the virus in
the future and I think that that is
likely to be the case
in many patients who are being worked up
for other sexually transmitted
infections such as HSV syphilis we may
need to test for mpox virus alongside
other what we've considered more common
causes of those STI infections
here's just some data on the positivity
rates uh both nationally and what we're
seeing at Mayo Clinic so over on the
right hand side of the slide our data
from this Centers for Disease Control
and you can see that in July the
positivity rate peaked out at around 50
percent but you can also see at that
time that the number of tests overall
being performed was very low as testing
expanded we actually saw the positivity
rates start to decline but it's really
plateaued over the course of the last
three four months at around 20 25
percent
if we look at our specific data at Mayo
Clinic our October positivity rate for
monkey pox was 29 percent
now I just want to compare and contrast
that to some other common sexually
transmitted infections our historical
positivity rate for chlamydia is around
five percent trichomonas is the same
five percent gonorrhea two and a half
percent mycoplasma genitalium about 10
percent
we do between five thousand and six
thousand tests per month for chlamydia
and trichomonas and gonorrhea with
positivity rates of two and a half to
five percent
my thought is we are not testing nearly
enough for impox virus if our positivity
rates are above 20 percent Nationwide
I'd really like us to get consistently
the positivity or rates of five percent
or less
uh before we start to feel very
comfortable that the current outbreak is
under control
so just to summarize prior to this year
mpox was a very rare cause of disease
outside the continent of Africa this is
the largest outbreak in recorded history
it spread currently primarily through
direct contact with an infected lesion
or through contact with contaminated
objects such as bed spread or clothing
unfortunately the clinical presentation
can be highly variable from mild to
severe and this is what is contributing
to continued spread of the virus in the
population
the diagnosis is based on an
individual's exposure history their
clinical presentation and lab testing
and currently we have good tools to
diagnose these infections and growing
number of of commercial assays that are
being authorized for use and diagnosis
dermal and genital lesion swabs are the
recommended specimen types at this point
viral culture shouldn't be ordered in
suspect cases and I really feel like
impox virus is likely here to stay at
least for the foreseeable future and I'd
like to see again those positivity rates
be south of five percent
before we start to declare that the
current outbreak is under control
here's a few references that you can go
to to get some additional information on
impacts virus and the current outbreak
again want to thank C Gene and lab roots
for the opportunity to discuss the
ongoing outbreak with you and I'll look
forward to answering any questions you
might have
thank you
Dr benicker for your informative
presentation if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box and
click Send we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
some recent reports have suggested that
monkey pox can be carried
asymptomatically is there a role for
asymptomatic testing
yeah great question so obviously a lot
of interest around asymptomatic testing
during the covid pandemic and we know
through a lot of studies and really
strong data with covid that the virus
can be
spread efficiently from those who lack
symptoms we don't know yet with impacts
whether asymptomatic transmission is a
major cause of disease transmission
now the studies that have been done have
shown that the virus can be detected
from other sample types like blood semen
urine the throat but at much lower rates
than
uh dermal genital lesions
so
the CDC has been conducting an ongoing
study looking at individuals who are
exposed to impox virus but haven't yet
developed symptoms and those individuals
are having multiple sample types
collected nasal swabs throat swabs blood
samples urine specimens to see what the
detection rates in various sample types
look like until an individual begins to
develop clinical disease and I'm looking
forward to the data from that study
being published I think it will really
inform whether asymptomatic testing is
going to be
feasible and useful or whether it won't
be useful as it has been with cobit 19.
great thank you our next question asks
you indicated mpvx is sticking around
when is it appropriate for testing to be
part of a panel of other lesions causing
pathogens
yeah I think we're already at a point
where as a laboratory director I would
like to have that tool in my laboratory
in other words having a panel of uh
impox virus along with HSV
uh potentially vzv as a cause of skin
lesions so that we can perform that uh
screen and and rule out on on different
uh skin dermal lesions for uh what we've
considered common causes of dermal
genital lesions and now impox virus
which we can include in that in that
list so I really encourage
um
commercial manufacturers to consider
panels because I think that they would
be a valuable tool for Physicians and
clinical laboratories
great thank you that brings me to my
next question the initial symptom in
patients with monkey pox can manifest as
oropharyngeal symptoms which include
pharyngitis
epiglottitis and Odin Aphasia how do I
send an oral sample for testing to the
laboratory
yeah so if a patient has
lesions in their mouth or throat
that a physician suspects could be due
to Monkey pox it's appropriate to swab
that lesion and send it in just as they
would a dermal or genital lesion
that's appropriate to collect it's
appropriate to test because as was
brought up in the question
patients can develop lesions in the
mouth and throat
especially after receptive oral sex
being a means of transmitting epox virus
so that that would be the recommended
testing approach
great thank you our next question is
would that be sexual transmission in
general or rather between men
um so this is an important issue to
bring up and discuss
although early on in the outbreak many
of the cases of impacts were in the men
who have sex with men population
it is inaccurate to refer to this as a
disease that is specific to that
population because we have seen impacts
virus infections occurring in other
populations as well anyone who comes in
close contact with a an infected lesion
can contract the disease it's even still
a question of whether impox virus should
be categorized as a sexually transmitted
disease or not there are other routes
that this virus can be transmitted by we
talked about contaminated fomites being
a source of transmission
so while we know that this virus can be
transmitted through close intimate
contact including sexual contact there
are other routes that can result in the
virus being transmitted so that's why
it's really important to be careful
about the way that we talk about
transmission routes with this particular
infection
thank you our next question is do the
latest smallpox and npox vaccines cause
blistering and Scar formations like the
old smallpox vaccines
yeah I I think the answer to that is
know that we're not seeing the same type
of of blistering as we saw with patients
you know decades ago who were receiving
smallpox vaccines
um
so I don't think that that is a uh as a
concern as as it was in the past
great my next
would those manifestations that appear
to be somewhat irregular be due to the
Epic the endemic aspects of where it
originated in one of those two areas in
question in Africa or would there be
another reason or cause
yeah
so in general infections due to clade 2
which was previously the the West
African have been more minor in terms of
the the disease severity and the
mortality rate and that is the clade
that is causing the current outbreak and
so I think that's uh a possible
explanation as to why we're seeing a
different a range of of severity of
lesions whereas clade 1 or that Central
African Congo base in clade usually is
associated with a more severe disease
presentation
more lesions and higher mortality rates
so I think that there likely is an
aspect of the the type the strain of the
virus that's causing the current
outbreak with the um in most situations
less severe type of clinical
presentation
great thank you our next question is why
are dry swabs or those collected in vtn
compatible with testing but not swabs in
UTM
that is a great question and we we've
asked that to
the CDC and
it comes down to the validation that the
Centers for Disease Control
performed and they've specifically
indicated to performing Laboratories
that dry swabs and swabs and viral
transport media specifically are the
ones that are approved whereas swabs in
Universal transport media are not
considered on label for the CDC test
um I think that myself along with you
know many Clinical Laboratory directors
feel that there is a lot of similarity
between viral transport media and
Universal transport media but currently
we're only accepting swabs and vtm for
that reason I think if a lab wants to
perform some comparison studies and show
that swabs and UTM is acceptable
that that is a possibility with a
bridging study and if companies also
want to develop and validate swabs in
UTM now that there's the eua process
that that uh
opens it up for more flexibility with
regards to the type of transport media
that can be used
great thank you our next question is in
September the CDC issued guidance for
concern that the California variant of
monkey pox contained a mutation that
affected the target PCR Gene for the CDC
West African monkey pox assay how
frequent is this variant have you seen
it in samples submitted to the Mayo
Clinic for testing
yeah I'm glad this question came up and
there have been a number of uh studies
and a recent publication showing that
there can be instances where the virus
may have a deletion present that can
render certain molecular tests
as
unable to detect that particular variant
I don't think the frequency is high
and fortunately the majority of testing
that's been used to date has not been
for specific clades where we're seeing
this deletion issue cause more problems
but instead most of the testing is being
done at the genus level which seems to
um in some ways sidestep the deletion
issue but it's something that we
continue to need to monitor as we saw
with covid-19 there are different
variants and strains in circulation and
Laboratories and Commercial
manufacturers will need to continue to
sequence these strains and ensure that
the assays that they're using are able
to detect these strains effectively
great thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question today
and that question is which type of swab
is the most useful for mpox diagnosis
so if the if the question is to the
exact type of swab
um I would refer
um the participants to go to the CDC
website if they're sending samples to a
laboratory that's using the CDC test
um
the CDC outlines that there are certain
types of swabs like cotton swabs that
should not be used
but dermal and genital swabs are the
preferred specimen type I know that some
commercial manufacturers are validating
specific commercial swabs or maybe even
their own proprietary swab and transport
media so it really depends on the test
as to what type of swab and then
potentially transport media is going to
be a useful for diagnosis
great thank you and it looks like that
brings us to the end of our q a session
for today thank you Dr biniker do you
have any final comments for our audience
just appreciate everybody taking the
time to join me today for this uh
overview of of impox and I hope that um
the rest of the year goes smoothly for
everybody in the 2023 will be uh quieter
and we can focus on
um what we uh what we want to focus on
instead of emerging infectious diseases
thank you
yes thank you again Dr biniker for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor CG Technologies for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
words will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye